senio ribelli ma proprio belli quante
volte avete visto questa maglia non
realtà è che sto registrando sfido un po
tutti di fila perché cercando di
italiani almeno una settimana dove vado
in vacanza quindi nè che non mi lavo
cioè non milano si mi lavo però mi metto
la stessa maglia dopo che mi sono lavato
che ve ne frega poi come volevo dirvi è
che siamo su over grock siamo ritornati
episodio 2 anche se non li metto come
episodi perché ci è passato un secolo
dall'ultima volta che ci ho giocato è un
gioco della madonna quindi ha subito
così va bene
come vedi è fortificata sì lo vedo per
non mi ricordo i tasti ho capito quindi
non so bene come si fa ma l'ho chiamato
giocavo joystick io non so se il mar
infatti mi sa che con gesti che non ci
giochiamo stavo scherzando over gold e
questo gioco molto bello dove tu in
persone in un coniglio male qualche
animale strano che sta in piedi e devi
spaccare di botte i nemici è veramente
figo come gioco però non mi ricordo
dov'eravamo rimasti a me noi spacchiamo
di botti nemici comunque permesso salve
va bene un ninja lega un [ __ ] dice
nico 9 scusa io io cammino così ogni
tanto lo faccio perché mi diverto ma c'è
un entrata in questo posto dobbiamo
continuare così a genero questo
camminare sui muri sorry sì ma se non mi
dite l'entrata io continuo così finché
non lo trovo giusto
poi c'è una porta permesso aprite il
corriere non si apre in qualche modo
dovrò fare scusami amaci un tronco qua
se no cosa è stata una roccia a posso
usare questa come è giusto
mamma mia mamma mi ha guardato
assassin's creed chi prova a saltare giù
a complimenti l'hai preso in pieno non
sa proprio che più che pesci prendere
l'hack è male eh vabbè faccio un po
cagare ma perché non mi ricordo più come
si gioca solo per quell ora proviamo
un'attività sti posso anche lanciarle le
armi giusto come si lanciano le armi
nicolò più si può della squadra c'è una
spada nella schiena zio non sospese
accorto e grossa si vede non è morto e
vabbè tieniti traspare da lascio di
ricordo è anzi la usi quando ti vuoi a
prendere a casa
stendino succhia che male gli ho fatto
salve sono lo share toni vendo coltelli
tieni provalo ti piace scavalca mi sa
che hai a che male
l'hack è male che è male è
difficilissimo e passato un sacco di
tempo all'ultimo atto che ci ha giocato
per questo nemico più ok c'è ancora uno
e morto uno cavolo cavolo che palle
porca vacca morta dai riuscito a farli
fuori tutti arrivato l'ultimo dove
affetta la gente abbia affettiamo vabbè
modonna di dio
madonna di dio se io ti tiro una porca
vacca di lasciata in bocca e non mori
perché seme dati di tu sì allora porco
schifo niente io ti tiro io li madonna
ed io che tiro una botta con la spada
niente lui col calcio a posto mi uccide
a svegli adesso qua uno è moscia e
rodriguez abbia finiti adesso c'è il
boss dente lungo sono tutti andati la
mia famiglia
pagherai per questo senti dente grosso
regate questo minchia forte il tizio ero
through gas è schiatta di mortacci detto
sorella morta è morto sei un guerriero
benedetto no è che ho rifatto 20 volte
alla missione altro che benedetto
benedetto e lui sa mai cosa seria o una
lancia che storia prove del secondo non
lo so è una donna che ma
va bene me lo sono meritato 1 1
e stato bellissimo
volevi ecco a me non mi ha ucciso
semplicemente perché era un coso di
legno sto continuando a rotolare
rotoliamo giù dalla montagna va bene
riproviamoci prova a prendere in tutti
lui né una botta sola no luca premio
premio premio veloce e prendi la in
quanto tempo che male io sono vivo si è
fatto malissimo questo qui però sono
vivo come ho fatto a prendere dalle armi
è ok
let's go baby ci ha messo un'ora e mezzo
ma ce l'ho fatta bene dobbiamo fare
fuori tutti questi va bene sfida
accettata al volo zio che male non l'ho
mancato di mortacci sua ayachi dolore
chi è che mi stoffa e vabbè la morte più
bella del secolo va bene
11 torna che male ok quindi che prese a
calci in bocca questi va bene ai miei di
zio ma ho vinto io occhio che mi vuoi
che me l'ha lanciata qua lancia io
lancia io lancia io l'ho preso
no oddio lo scrivano l'ultimo perfetto è
schietta e morto ho vinto
l'udc è bello sto gioco di conigli con
le lance in teoria ci dovrebbe essere
una storia ogni volta che parte un
livello c'è una didascalia che io non
leggo mai perché chi se ne fregano le
storie legge ma devo riuscire a scalare
sta roba
sì per in teoria questo un gioco anche
di parkour quindi fai un po tutte e due
le cose però sono un po impedito nel
parkour non so se si è visto oh che
bello dova domo ala effetto effetto
perfetto
amici sono capace fino a un certo punto
però ecco devo andare eccoci perché
siamo esattamente gli devo apprendere
qua ma va a cagare non sia peso ma
lurido coniglio apprendi di aver
scaliamo vi sempre
ciao ho trovato i miei amici che mi
porteranno immissione credo non lo so
fatemi vena i topi i lupi quello che
volete ma noi canicani misto simpatici
che lo fa è un allenamento forse forse
gli hack e male che calci che ha
inventato sto ciò che veramente ci aveva
dei problemi
poi c'è un coltello non è un allenamento
è un coltello di plastica o non è
allenamento mi sa che non è allenamento
questo questa gente seria non vuoi dare
qualcosa per favore io quando ho il
coltello qua quando ce l'hanno loro
porco il demonio incastrato nel divano
non c'è verso di tagliatelo non glielo
toglie manco morto pure da morto lo
tiene jolo perfetto complimento non ha
avuto scampo
ma lei of ages nomi come come fai a
essere vivo ecco premio moret poletti
deve morire la famiglia pure dai pure
pure ma mou ma dai mi chiama davo
fortuna partite della madonna gli ho
tolto il coltello non muore già prendi
più calci tu che il pallone dei mondiali
e rimane in piedi
ok no no no con di strani lo distrae
mieli di spawn non so parlare perché lo
tuo attacco to fall of war iii tour
madonna a calci o codici gesù a calci
ancora me ne frega continua ancora altra
gente
qual è la sola livello anche amici mi sa
che concludiamo quel video erano
interesso riuscito a beccare la roccia
va bene ma questo non lo faccio fuori
dai c'è un'arma trovato un'arma prendila
o sono armato un andato non hanno più
armi ok il 20 lo le schiave vi è morto
mio compagno ma chissenefrega tanto che
serviva mio compagno è morto come fa
essere lì hanno gli devo fare strada
tema non sono anche dobbiamo andare non
ho seguito niente vabbè se seguimi so io
dove andare
[Musica]
credo fortemente che non dovesse andare
così sarò nelle cellule non me ne frega
niente di quello che stai dicendo zio va
avanti era nell'antartide insomma i
figli sul livello di dark souls come
questo è più o meno l'acqua quando mi
faccio la doccia io credo dopo che
facendo va beh non spieghiamo se cose
che non sa maniera io mi immagino tutta
la storia che c'è dietro sto gioco
quadrata io avrei dovuto seguire no
quindi c'è una vera storia c'è un perché
siamo qui ma non avendolo seguito non lo
so e mi faccio delle storie mi e cioè
che sono carine tipo sembra sembra uno
sotto effetto di lsd pane la mia storia
ci sono i conigli che combattono sono
stato qua come dovrei riuscire a farlo
sicuramente già fatta con quale fisica
non lo so ma ce l'ho fatta va bene qui
dovrà arrivare alla fine del lago se
molto bene ad e vigenti a 1 st de vengo
in pace non mi attaccate salve non
nostra qui tranquilli c'è un cespuglio
che sai gioca a porta e io credo che su
sto gioco ci siano dei ranghi cioè nel
senso se trovi il topo è più facile da
battere se trovi il cane più difficile
il gatto è ancora più difficile del cane
il coniglio che va a fuoco è un casino
per quello che lo dico io
prendete la legge ero in antartide ho
picchiato dei conigli sono passato in
una palude ho picchiato dei topi fine
del racconto adesso siamo nel giardino
dei fiori ti picchiamo pietro a usare il
parkour penso che posso perché mi dovete
far fare sagoma kebe frega
tutto sto casino per fare deliver hope f
ok perfetto così 5 cielo arriva dove
devo andare qua ad altro tronco li
mortacci mia
bravo comunque i salti completamente
anti fisici e tutto quello che volete ma
salto e polo porco demonio voglio
rivederla
cos'è sta roba cosa che so io cosa sto
facendo avevi che era veramente del
libero
monsignor civo in giro just eat jas
coniglio penso sia finito così ragazzi
oculoplastici è un gioco dalle mille
sorprese crasha
che è veramente figo ragazzi e concludo
che episodi o perché spero che video vi
sia piaciuto vado a mangiare che mi il
coniglio ma ha portato della roba
spero questi ragazzi avete bisogno mi
piace che sia sono questi gli skater e
non ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
[Musica]